- Okay. So a lot has been said recently
and we don't need to rash it.
I wouldn't like to, but
how, because I get it,
but how do you keep your
composure when so much
of your private life is made public?
- I mean, the thing is like...
- It's hard.
It's hard sometimes.
And you know.
But in the end of the
day, like, I'm so lucky,
like, I'm so lucky and
there's people dealing with so
many really hard things.
Like, the people of Jackson,
Mississippi don't have water.
There's people everywhere dealing with
like, real health crises.
And you know, my stuff is
out there, but I'm alive
and my kids are alive and
that's what gets me through.
I remind myself of that every single day.
- You have to so you don't get resentful.
- Exactly.
And like I said, like
once you stop trying to
control the narrative, I
mean, I'm not on the internet.
I don't, I'm not on Instagram.
- I don't advise it.
Like, I don't do, I literally tell,
especially all the young
people that come in
as a young musician,
although I'm like, just like,
I get that it's for work
but don't live on it.
That'll, it's no good for anyone.
You're either gonna drink your own Koolaid
and think you're amazing.
- Exactly.
- Or you're gonna wanna
crawl in a hole and die.
So neither option is, is
super great for anyone.
- Exactly. So I think that really helps.
And just, yeah, focusing on what's real,
your trusted circle of friends,
what's real, things that make you happy,
people you love people who love you
and like just stick, keeping your mind
on what's real.
I think that's how I get through it.
And also watching people, my
colleagues get through it.
I mean, I think like, you're
a real great example of that.
Like I said, like, you come out here
and you smile and you laugh
and you give joy and like,
that's inspiring to me.
And I'm sure a lot of other people,
who are going through hard things.
So that's why this is, this is important.
And I think God, like, you know,
it could be a lot worse
and we're alive and
everything's gonna be okay.